[Music]
you look beautifuller I mean fuller you
don't look fuller but more more
beautiful thank you
what's it like being one of only two
Disney Princesses to have a confirmed
birthday Elsa it means that we know even
more about you as we match off your
personality traits against the typical
qualities of your zodiac sign it also
means that all of the other Disney
Princesses have no excuse for forgetting
your special day we know you could never
let it go if they did we are revealing
all of the Disney Princesses zodiac
signs including mal Evie and Audrey from
descendants keep watching to discover
Anna and Elsa's star signs based on
their actual birthdays it's further
proof that these sisters are total
opposites this is the best day of my
life and quite possibly the last
Aquarius
Aquarians wants to make the world a
better place they have a strong sense of
social justice so it's no wonder they're
often rebellious activists they also
value equality and hate being
underestimated
Aquarians never stands back in the face
of adversity sound familiar
LaVon totally matches that description
right but she's not the only one
Pocahontas also fits the bill perfectly
we're not too surprised that move on
ends Pocahontas were born under the same
sign they're just so similar was to
prove I could do things right Pisces
of course to fish represents Pisces so
we have to place Ariel aka The Little
Mermaid right where she belongs
those born under this water sign are
creative and intelligent they feel
things very deeply and are compassionate
and sensitive Souls Ariel sure felt the
pool toward lands deeply and she was
mighty creative with her dinglehopper
Rapunzel is also one of the most
creative princesses and she had that
Piscean psychic gut instinct to follow
the lanterns Aries fiery Aries are
courageous determined leaders it sounds
like we've just described Moana doesn't
it those born under the first sign of
the zodiac are known as trailblazers
they're impulsive spirit means they take
risks and Moana certainly did that
she also fits another sign to stay tuned
for that Taurus the Bull represents
Taurus and like a bull they can be
stubborn that also means that they're
responsible people who value security
these practical calm honest souls are
the anchor of the zodiac and isn't evey
mouth anchor as well as the rest of the
descendant squads she's also got the
typical tourist trait of being
hard-working those dresses don't design
themselves you know Tiana is arguably
the most hardworking of all the
princesses but we've got another sign
for her coming up next time Gemini
Gemini's are the chatterboxes of the
zodiac they're playful inquisitive and
love company but naturally the sign
represented by the twins has another
side and we all know how Audrey the
queen of mean had two sides to her in
descendants no offence mini bear just
trusting all of those positive
attributes sound like Anna but she sits
between two zodiac signs and for good
reason
cancer Anna also matches the description
of a typical cancer their emotional
imaginative and very sensitive use
by yourself for me I love you it's no
surprise honest straddles the two signs
being born on June 21st
Jennifer Lee frozen screenwriter and
co-director revealed on Twitter that
Anna was born on the summer solstice
that's the longest day of the year in
the northern hemisphere Leo Leo's are
bold self disciplined overachievers
these courageous adventurous types are
natural-born leaders sounds like Moana
and Mulan right but we've already
revealed their zodiac signs so we're
placing Tiana as our Leo princess you'd
see Tiana's picture next to the
dictionary definition of self-discipline
Virgo who's that shy girl sitting over
there
it's a Virgo of course with her nose in
a book sounds like Val right virgos are
intelligent logical and total
perfectionist these independent types
don't need a man like Gaston virgos are
loyal and self-sacrificing too just like
how Belle took her father's place in the
dungeon Libra when the scales of justice
represents a sign you know that fairness
is important and that's what Cinderella
is all about like a typical Libra is
she's cooperative and gracious libras
love socializing so it's no wonder
Cinderella was so keen to get to that
ball there non-confrontational types and
have a romantic and idealistic streak
it's like a dream a wonderful dream come
true so Aurora and Snow White's would
make perfect fellow libras too Scorpio
passionate Scorpio is a strong
resourceful protective type
yep that's mal all over the descendents
Queen is wise beyond her years
assertive and powerful making her a
typical Scorpio I'm supposed to protect
Oregon you dude given that Scorpios are
also described as brave of course Merida
would be also born under the sign
Sagittarius who loves freedom as much as
a Sagittarian they adore adventure and
are easily bored yep we have basically
just described Jasmine she couldn't wait
to climb over the palace wall and get
out into the big wide world I've never
done a thing on my
I've never had a new real friends like a
typical Sagittarius Jasmine can be blunt
she wasn't exactly polite to Aladdin all
the time now was she there's another
freedom-loving princess that could fall
under the sign and that's Elsa but the
ice queen didn't quite make the cut
Capricorn Jennifer Lee also divulged the
day of Elsa's birth the winter solstice
Ana's opposite doesn't that make perfect
sense for these two sisters no I'm just
trying to protect you you don't have to
protect me I'm not afraid the shortest
day of the year in the northern
hemisphere falls between the 20th and 20
seconds of December so that means Elsa
could be a Sagittarian or Capricorn
Capricorn's are ambitious loyal to their
family disciplined and tenacious these
are all words that we'd use to describe
the Elsa we've seen in the frozen two
trailers sounds like Tiana too doesn't
it so that's a wrap on the Disney
Princesses zodiac signs do you feel a
connection with the princesses that
share the same sign as you be sure to
let us know in the comments subscribe to
the things for more Disney Princess
videos like this one thanks for watching
we'll see you soon
[Music]